du warst also am pannen flughafen hat
das einmal alles miterlebt wie das so
läuft was ist dein fazit wird er im
oktober hat sich aufmachen können ja
mein fazit ist ein sehr gemischtes ich
bin mit einem mulmigen gefühl heraus
gekommen zum einen haben wir einen
fertigen baulich fertigen flughafen in
denen nur noch die shops eingebaut
werden müssen dass sie zwar dramatisch
aus aber auch messebauer kriegen so was
innerhalb von wenigen wochen in vielem
omega ist das gefühl das einen
beschleicht wenn man sieht wie nichts
ineinander greift wie ganz wenige leute
dort nur bescheid wissen wie wichtige
wegweisungen fehlen etwa zur
sicherheitskontrolle zum gate und wenn
man dann zweimal vor passkontrollen
steht die schlicht und einfach nicht
besetzt sind weil die bundespolizei
nicht mitbekommen hat dass dort jetzt
kontrolliert wird oder den passagieren
nicht klar ist zu welcher zur kontrolle
sie gehen müssen
dann stellt man sich am ende schon die
frage auch wenn dpa pünktlich zum 31
oktober eröffnen sollte welches chaos
bricht den flugbetrieb auf